gender inequality in the pay gap between
men and women positively predicts both
male and female satisfaction in
relationships yeah but the more unequal
the earning opportunities are for men
and women skewed in the direction of men
not women the happier both men and women
are in their outcomes in relationships
and St home dads is a very strong
predictor of divorce yeah if the woman
is the primary bread winner man of 50%
more likely to use erectile dysfunction
medication women are more likely to be
on the receiving end of domestic if
they're the primary bread winner because
the male part
switches from a benefit affording to a
cost inflicting mate retention strategy
if you begin to feel a disparity in mate
value you have two choices start to
raise yourself up or try to drag the
other person down making them fearful of
you is a pretty good way to drag them
down that's kind of dark that being said
the patriarchy is so powerful that we've
somehow convinced women that they both
need to earn the money and that we can
stay at home while they bear the burden
of children so maybe this is just a Scot
from all of us to not have to do
anything except for Xbox now